The best people in life are the ones who can pretty much find anything interesting
people who are curious about other people's passions
if you tell someone about the book or something you enjoy cooking
any passion that you have
and they find it interesting and they're curious about it
That makes them a better person
a better friend
when they're curious about your passions
whatever you're passionate about
they genuinely care and ask you questions
There’s nothing worse than when you wanna talk about your passions
and they're like
oh yeah cool..
they dismiss you or they don't care
or they just wanna change the topic or talk about themselves
Maybe their interest or passions aren't your thing
but why not be curious about them
You’re not asking too much to have
someone emotionally understand you
and hear you are
that's why I think people who are curious and interested of your passions
are the best kinds of people/friends